you've talked about it but it's just
interesting the intensity of feeling you
have you've you've had this famous
phrase about Hunter Biden and children
in the basement can you just revisit
this case so let me
let me give another perspective on the
situation of January 6th and Trump in
general
it's possible that January 6th and
things of that nature revealed to our
democracy is actually pretty fragile
and then Trump is not a malevolent an
ultra competent malevolent figure but
it's simply a jokester
and he just by creating the chaos
revealed that it's all pretty fragile
because you're a student in history and
there's a lot of people like Vladimir
Lenin Hitler who are exceptionally
competent at controlling power
at being Executives and taking that
power controlling the generals
controlling all the figures involved and
certainly not tweeting but working in
the shadows behind the scenes to gain
power and they did so extremely
confidently and that is how they were
able to gain power the the pushback with
Trump is was doing none of that he was
creating what he's very good at creating
drama
sometimes for humor's sake sometimes for
drama's sake and simply reveal that our
democracy is fragile and so he's not
this uh once in a generation horrible
figure once in a generation narcissist
no I I don't think he's he's a
a truly scary Sinister you know
putin-like or you know Hitler much less
hitler-like figure not at all I mean
he's not ideological he doesn't care
about anything beyond himself so it's
not
um
no no he's much less scary than any
really scary you know totalitarian right
I mean and he's he's more Brave New
World than 1984. this is what you know
Eric Weinstein never stops um
badgering me about but you know he's
still wrong Eric
um you know I I can you know my analogy
for Trump was that he's an evil Chauncey
Gardener I don't know if you remember
the the
um the the book or the film being there
uh with it with Peter Sellers
um but you know Peter Sellers is this
Gardener who really doesn't know
anything
um but he gets recognized as this wise
man and he gets promoted to immense
power in Washington because he's
speaking in these kind of in a semblance
of wisdom he's got these very simple
aphorisms or it would seem to be
aphorisms he's just talking all he cares
about is gardening he's just talking
about his garden all the time but you
know he'll say something but yeah you
know in the spring you know the new
shoots will will Bloom and people read
into that some kind of Genius you know
Insight politically and so he gets
promoted and so that's that's the joke
of the film for me Trump has always been
someone like an evil Chauncey Gardner
he's he's
not to say he's totally yes he has a
certain kind of Genius he's got a genius
for creating a spectacle around himself
right he's got a genius for getting the
the eye of the media always coming back
to him
um but it it's only it's a kind of
it's a kind of you know self-promotion
that only works if you actually are
truly Shameless and don't care about
having a reputation for anything that
that I or you would want to have a
reputation for right it's like it's pure
the pure pornography of attention right
and he just wants more of it
um I think that truly depressing and
genuinely scary thing was that
we have a country that at least half of
the country given how
uh
broken our society is in many ways we
have a country that didn't see anything
wrong with that or bringing someone
who's uh who obviously doesn't know what
he should know to be president
and who's obviously not a good person
right obviously doesn't care about
people can't even pretend to care about
people really right in a credible way
um
and so I mean this if there's a silver
line into this it it's it's along the
lines you just sketched it shows us how
vulnerable our system is to a truly
brilliant and Sinister figure right I
mean like a I I think we are
um we really dodged a bullet yeah
someone far more competent
and conniving and ideological could have
exploited our system in a way that Trump
didn't and and that's um yeah so if if
we
plug those holes eventually
um that would be a good thing and he
would have done a good thing for our
society right I mean one of the things
we realized
and I think nobody knew I mean I
certainly didn't know it and I didn't
hear anyone talk about it
is how much our system
relies on Norms rather than laws yes
civility yeah it's just like it's it's
quite possible that he never did
anything illegal you know truly truly
illegal I maybe I think he probably did
a few illegal things but like a legal
such that he really should be thrown in
jail for it you know
um at least that remains to be seen
so all of the chaos all of the you know
all of the
diminishment of our stature in the world
all of the Just the the opportunity
costs of spending years focused on
nonsense
um
all that was just Norm violations
all that was just that was just all a
matter of not saying the thing you
should say but that doesn't mean they're
insignificant right it's not that it's
like it's not illegal for a sitting
president to say
no I'm not going to commit to a peaceful
transfer of power right we'll wait and
see whether I win if I win
it was the election was was was valid if
I lose it was fraudulent right but
aren't those
humorous perturbations to our system of
Civility such that we know where the
limits are and now we start to think
that and have these kinds of discussions
but that wasn't a humorous perturbation
because he did everything he could
granted he wasn't very competent but he
did everything he could to try to steal
the election I mean the irony is he
claimed to have an election stolen from
him all the while doing everything he
could to steal it declaring it
fraudulent in advance trying to get the
votes to to not be counted as the
evening wore on knowing that they were
going to be disproportionately Democrat
Democrat votes
um because of the the you know because
of the position he took on mail-in
ballots I mean all of it was fairly
calculated
the whole circus of of of you know the
clown car that crashed into you know
Four Seasons Landscaping right and and
he got Rudy Giuliani with his hair dying
you got Sydney Powell and all these
gross incompetent people lying as freely
as they could breathe about election
fraud right and all these things are
getting thrown out by you know
Republican largely Republican election
officials and Republican judges
um it wasn't it wasn't for want of
trying that he didn't maintain his power
in this country he really tried to steal
the presidency he just was not competent
and the people around him weren't
competent so that's a good thing and
it's worth not letting that happen again
but he wasn't competent so he didn't do
everything he could well he did
everything he could he didn't do
everything that could have been done by
someone more competent
right but the the tools you have as a
president you could do a lot of things
you can declare emergencies especially
doing covid you could postpone the
election you can create military
conflict that you know any kind of
reason to postpone the election there's
there's a lot of what he tried to do
things and he would have to have done
those things through other people and
they're people who refuse to do those
things or people who said they would
quit they would they would quit publicly
right I mean this is you start again
there are multiple books written about
uh all in the last hours of of this
presidency and the details are shocking
in what he tried to do and tried to get
others to do and it's awful right I mean
it's it's just awful that we were that
close
to something
um
to a true unraveling of our political
process and it's the only time in our
lifetime that anything like this has
happened and
um
is deeply embarrassing right for uh you
know on the world stage it's just like
we looked like a Banana Republic there
for a while and
where the lone superpower it's a bit
it's it's not good right and so we
shouldn't like there's no there's no the
I the people who thought well we just
need to shake things up and this is a
great great way to shake things up and
having people you know storm our capital
and smear on the walls that's just
more shaking things up right it's all
just for the lulls
um there's a nihilism and cynicism to
all of that which again in certain
people it's understandable you know
frankly it's not understandable if
you've got a billion dollars and you're
you you know have a compound in Menlo
Park or wherever it's like they're
people who are cheerleading this stuff
who shouldn't be cheerleading this stuff
and who know that they can get on their
Gulf Stream and fly to their compound in
New Zealand if everything goes to
right so there's a cynicism to all of
that that I think we should be deeply
critical of but what I'm trying to
understand is not
and analyze is not the behavior of this
particular human being but the effect it
had in part on the division between
people as to me the degree the meme
of Sam Harris's brain being broken by
Trump represents
you're like the person I would look to
to bridge the division
well I don't think there is
something profitably to be said
to someone who's truly captivated by the
the the personality Cult of trumpism
right like there's nothing that I'm
going to say to
there's no conversation I'm going to
have with Candace Owens say about Trump
that's going to converge on something
reasonable right you don't think so no I
mean I've tried I haven't tried with
Candace I've tried with you know many
people who
are in that particular orbit I mean I've
I've had conversations with people who
won't admit that there's anything wrong
with Trump anything so I'd like to push
for the empathy versus reason because
when you operate in a space of Reason
yes
but I think there's a lot of power
in you showing in you Sam Harris showing
that you're willing to see the good
qualities of trump publicly showing that
I think that's the way to win over okay
but he has so few of them he has fewer
good qualities than any virtually anyone
I can name right but so he he's funny he
I'll grant you that he's funny he's he's
a good Entertainer there's others look
at just policies and actual impacts yeah
I've admitted that no no so like so I've
admitted that many of his policies I
agree with
many many of us probably so it
probably more often than not at least on
balance I agree so I I agreed with his
policy that you know we should take
China seriously as an adversary right
and
um I think I mean again that you have to
there's a lot of fine print to a lot of
this because the way he talks about
these things and and many of his motives
that are obvious or things that I um
don't support but I'm gonna take
immigration I think there's
it's obvious that we should have control
of our borders right like I I don't see
the argument for not having control of
our borders we should let in who we want
to let in and we should keep out who we
want to keep out and we should have the
same immigration policy so
um I don't I didn't necessarily think it
was a priority to build the wall but I
didn't I never criticized the impulse to
build the wall because if you know tens
of thousands hundreds of thousands of
people are coming across that border and
we are not in a position to know who's
coming
that seems untenable to me so
um and I can recognize that many people
in our society
are on balance the victims of
immigration
because and there is a in in many cases
a zero-sum contest between the interests
of actual citizens and the interests of
immigrants right so I think we should
have a we should have control of our
borders we should have a sane and
compassionate immigration policy we
should have we should let in refugees
right so I you know Trump on refugees
was terrible
um but
no like I would say 80 of the policy
concerns people
uh celebrated in him
are concerns that I either share
entirely or certainly sympathize with
right so like that's not
that's not the issue the issue is
a threat to democracy and something well
the issue is largely what you said it
was it's not so much the person it's the
effect on everything he touches right he
just he has this this superpower of
deranging and destabilizing
uh almost everything he touches and
Sully in the and compromising the
Integrity of almost anyone who comes
into his orbit I mean so he looked at
these people who served you know as
Chief of Staff or you know in various
cabinet positions people had real
reputations you know for for probity and
and level-headedness uh you know whether
you share their politics or not I mean
these were real people these were not
you know some of them were goofballs but
um
uh
you know many people who who just got
totally trashed by
proximity to him and then Trashed by him
when they finally parted company with
him
um
yeah I mean there's just people bent
over backwards to accommodate his Norm
violations and it it was it was bad for
them it was bad for our
our system and
but then but none of that discounts the
fact that
we have
A system that really needs a proper
house cleaning yes there are bad
incentives and
um entrenched interests and yeah I'm not
a fan of the concept of of
the Deep State uh but because it you
know has been so propagandized but yes
there's there's something like that you
know that is uh not um
flexible enough to respond intelligently
to the needs of the moment right so
there's a lot of rethinking of
government and of institutions in
general that I think
we should do
but we need smart well-informed
well-intentioned people to do that job
and the well-intentioned part is
is hugely important right it's Gentlemen
Just give me someone
who
is not the most
selfish person anyone has ever heard
about in their lifetime right and what
we got with Trump was the like the
literally the one most selfish person I
think anyone could name
I mean and you and again you there's so
much known about this man that's the
thing it's like it predates his
presidency we knew this guy 30 years ago
yeah and and this and this is why to
come back to the those inflammatory
comments about Hunter Biden's laptop
the reason why I can say with confidence
that I don't care what was on his his
laptop is that there is and and that
includes any evidence of corruption on
the on the part of his father right now
there's been precious little of that
that's actually emerged so it's like
there is no as far as I can tell there's
not a big story associated with that
laptop as much as people bang on about a
few emails but
even if there were just obvious
corruption right like Joe Biden was at
this meeting and he took you know this
amount of money from this Shady guy
uh for bad reasons right
given how visible the lives of these two
men have been right given how much we
know about Joe Biden and how much we
know about Donald Trump and how they
have lived in public for almost as long
as I've been alive both of them
the the the the scale of corruption
can't possibly balance out between the
two of them right we I if if you show me
the Joe Biden has this secret life or
he's driving a Bugatti and he's living
like Andrew Tate right and he's do he's
doing all these things I didn't know
about okay then I'm gonna start getting
a sense that all right maybe this guy is
way more corrupt than I realize maybe
there is some deal in Ukraine or with
China that is just like this guy is not
who he seems he's not the public servant
he's been pretending to be he's been on
the take for decades and decades and
he's just he's as dirty as can be he's
all mobbed up and it's a nightmare
um and he can't be trusted right that's
possible
if you show me that his life is not at
all what it seems but on the assumption
that I having looked at this guy for
literally decades right and and knowing
that every journalist has looked at him
for decades just how many Affairs does
he have and just how much you know how
many drugs is he doing how many houses
does he have where you know what what
what is what are the obvious conflicts
of interest you know you hold that
against what we know about Trump right
and
I mean the Litany of indiscretions you
can put on Trump's side that that
testify to his personal corruption to
testify the fact that he has no ethical
compass
there's simply no comparison right so
that's why I don't care about what's on
the laptop when now if you tell me Trump
is no longer running for president in
2024 and we can put trumpism behind us
and now you're saying listen there's a
lot of stuff on that laptop that makes
Joe Biden look like a total okay
I'm all ears right I mean it was a force
in 2020 it was a force choice between
a sitting president who wouldn't commit
to a peaceful transfer of power
and a guy who's obviously too old
to be president who has a crack addicted
son who who you know who lost his laptop
and I just knew that I was going to take
Biden in spite of whatever Litany of
Horrors was going to come tumbling out
of that laptop and that might involve
sort of so the actual quote is Hunter
Biden literally could have had the
corpses of children in the basement
there's a dark humor to it right which
is I think you speak to I would not have
cared there's nothing it's Hunter Biden
it's not Joe Biden whatever the scopo
Joe Biden's corruption is it is
infinitesimally compared to the
corruption we know Trump was involvement
it's like a firefly to the sun is what
you're speaking to but let me make the
case that you're really focused on the
surface stuff
that it's possible to have corruption
that masquerades in the thing we
mentioned which is civility you comment
you can spend hundreds of billions of
dollars or trillions towards the War uh
in the Middle East for example something
that you've changed your mind on in
terms of the negative impact it has on
the world and that you know the military
industrial complex
it's everybody's very nice everybody's
very civil it's very upfront here's how
we're spending the money yeah sometimes
somehow disappears in different places
but that's the way you know war is
complicated and it's everyone is very
polite there's no uh Coke and strippers
or whatever is on the laptop
um it's very nice and polite in the
meanwhile hundreds of thousands of
civilians die uh hate and just an
incredible amount of hate is created
because people lose their family members
all that kind of stuff but there's no
strippers in Coke on a laptop so yeah
but but it's not just superficial it is
when you when someone only wants wealth
and power and fame and so this is that
is their their objective function right
they're like a a robot that is
calibrated just to those variables right
and they don't care about the risks we
run on any other front they don't care
about I mean
environmental risk pandemic risk nuclear
proliferation risk none of it right they
just they're just tracking Fame and
money and and whatever can can
personally uh re down to their
self-interest along those lines and
they're not informed about the other
risks we're running really I mean in
Trump you had a president who was
repeatedly asking his generals why
couldn't we use our nuclear weapons why
can't we have more of them why do I have
fewer nuclear weapons than JFK right as
though that were a sign of of of
anything other than progress right
um
and this is the guy who's got the the
the button right I mean he's got
somebody's following him around with a
bag waiting to take his order to to
Launch